مقعد درعي اليمين نتنياهو بقي فارغا مع
بدايه جلسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن درع
اعاده فوصل متاخرا وكانه يلمح الى ان
اقالته ليست نهايه المطاف لكنني تنياه
الطره الى توقيع كتاب قالته من منصبه
وزيرا في الحكومه عملا بقرار القضاء لتدخل
الاقاله حيز التنفيذ الثلاثاء المقبل
ويدرس نتنياهو ان كان ابقاء درعي في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المصغره بصفه مراقب
وتصب لاغاله الزيت على نار المواجهه
القائمه على خلفيه محاوله الحكومه اضعاف
النظام القضائي ويخضعه لقرارات السياسيه
ان يصبح الفصل بين السلطات شعارا لا ينفذ
سيجعل جهاز القضائي راضي يخلي الوزاراته
وسياسه الحكومه بدون قدره على منع وقف
خطواتنا تمسح حقوق المواطنه وبعضها يتعلق
بمواضيع امنيه ايضا الى جانب ازمه درع بدا
التصدعات في اختلاف الحكوميه حيث قاطعوا
وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه برئاسه مودريتش
جلسه الحكومه احتجاجا على تفكيك
باراستيطانيه فور اقامتها من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
واكتشاف مودريتش ان الجيش لا ينصع لامره
بعدم التنفيذ رغم انه وزير في وزاره
الدفاع فيما طالب الوزير المتطرف من كبير
بهدم تجمع الخان الاحمر الفلسطيني في اسرع
وقت
لن يكون هناك قانون للعرب وقانون لليهود
وعندما يطبق القانون يجب ان يطبق على
الخان الاحمر وعشرات البؤر التي اقامها
العرب القانون هو القانون ولن تكون فيه
تفرقه
نتنياه يجتهد في محاوله تهدئه المخاوف
الامريكيين واقناعهم بانه يسيطر على زمام
الامور ولا يترك ذلك لوزاره المتطرفين لكن
ذلك قد يجعل اتمام حكومته ولايتها
القانونيه الكامله موضع شكا حيث سيصط
بشركائه الطبيعيين ان اراد ارضاء
الاميركيين او اخرين زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه